[拍手]
[音楽]
pham
こんにちは
皆さんは
この世界にある前提のような既成概念に
ついてどう捉えていますか
ルールのようなもの
それともちょっと煩わしいものでしょうか
どのような環境にあってもそれは少なから
ず私たちの活動に影響を与えるでしょう
私はアーティストとして作品を制作する中
でそのような既成概念の裏側には発見が
あると感じてきました
発見とは自分が今まで気づかなかった価値
を見いだせるヒントになります
そもそも既成概念から出た発見とはどう
いうことなのか
作品をお見せしながらお話しするので
ちょっと変わった美術館を除いたなみたい
な気持ちで聞いてください
まずこれが私の作品です
私は染色の絞り染め技法を使って作品を
制作しています
素材は布でできているので立体的な作品や
空間に広がるような作品に入って適してい
ます
あそもそも絞り染め技法とは
布糸で巻き付けたり板で挟んだりして
部分的に線量が入らないようにすることで
模様を出す表現です
着物で見たことがある人もいると思います
日本の伝統的な染色技法の一つです
でも私はこの染色の絞り染め技法を使い
ながらも本来行うはずの染色をせずに布を
糸で巻いて縛った状態つまり染める前の
状態を表現として展開しています
つまり染める技法なのに染めないで表現を
しているんです
作り方は布に糸を巻きつけてそれを1本
ずつやっていきそれを連続することで絞り
の群衆を作り出しています
伝統的な技法を使いながらも別の表現方法
へ展開しているのはちょっと作品の着弾点
がみんなと違っているからです
着眼点とは
政策の中で見つけた発見のことをいいます
発見とは特に日常の当たり前の中で過ごし
ているこの日常から出た疑問
そこから得た発見には想像覆す力を持った
ものがあります
日常から出た疑問
言い換えれば
既成概念への疑問でもあります
たとえばさっき見たように絞り染めは
染めるもの
布は柔らかくて自立しないもの
作品は壁に飾るものという既成概念を
私たちは持っています
当たり前の事に対しても皆さんも疑問を
抱いたら立ち止まることがあると思います
私自身もなんで絞りて染めるのかな
なんで乗ってこんな柔らかくて自立しない
んだろう
なんで作品を毎回壁に飾るんだろうと
政策の中で当たり前だった既成概念に注目
するようになりました
ここでその感覚をちょっとだけ共有したい
ので
さっき話しした布は自立しないという既成
概念について
どうアプローチすればいいでしょうか
私は
柔らかいなら他のものに巻きつけてしまう
とこう考えました
布が柔らかくて自立しないのならばそれは
他のものを取り込めることにつながると
考えたんです
これは木材とか金属とかそういう方へもの
にはない特徴です
ちなみにこれは愉快たとか柱とかそういう
廃材を包むように絡めて構成してあります
自立しないということをデメリットとして
見るのではなくメリットとして生かせる
ようにしました
では次に
作品は壁に飾るという皆さんにもなじみが
あるこの既成概念について一緒に考えてみ
ましょう
この既成概念に対して疑問を見いだし
そこからどのように発見を導き出して解決
しますか
少し時間を取るので気分転換にちょっと
考えてみてください
どうですか
みなさんいろんな可能性を考えだと思い
ます
それはどれも正解でも間違えでもそういう
ものはありません
そのどれでも自分ならではの発見を見つけ
出したんじゃないでしょうか
ちなみに私は
作品ごと壁にしてしまうとこう考えました
作品が壁をぶち抜いて床に貼って出てき
ます
壁を単なる支持体として捉えるのではなく
空間性をもっと作品にしようとトライした
のが私の答えです
皆さんもっときっと良い発見を導き出した
と思うので後でこっそり私に教えて
ください
この2つを今井皆さんと一緒に考えてき
ましたがここで私が意識したことは既成
概念に対して疑問を抱いたときに全く別の
方法で解決をしないということです
私がさっきあったことは既成概念を含んだ
状態で別の方法を探しました
さっきの話だと布が柔らかくて自立しない
ということが気になるなら
頑丈でもっと厚い布にすればいいでしょう
壁から作品を解放したければ親父でに立体
にしたほうが話が早いかもしれません
でもその既成概念の枠にいながらそれを
超えることによって人によっては従来との
違いから新しさを想像しそれが結果的に他
との個別化にもつながります
例外年から白金に変えたことで今までとは
違う選択肢を選べるようになり
二次会えっとそれはかけていると思ってい
たデメリットが他にはないメリットとして
考え直されるきっかけになります
このように既成概念の裏側というかみな
さんが考えたいろんな側面には具体的な
発見が潜んでいます
これまで
既成概念からの発見についてお話ししてき
ましたが多分皆さん1年分の既成概念と
いう言葉を聞いたんじゃないでしょうか
なぜ私がここまで
しすごく既成概念に対して疑問抱くように
なったのか
きっかけは展覧会の時です
作品に対して肯定的な励ましの言葉に
混ざり
いやや工芸なんて
所詮選手でしょと言う
分野を否定する言葉を言われたんですね
作品に対して評価をするときになぜ
まるで分野を見下すような言葉が使われる
のか
疑問と
まあ正直怒りでいっぱいでした
悔しいなと思ってそれについて毎日
ドロドロしたマグマを抱えながらもそれに
ついての理由を聞いたんです
すると
工芸の分野は生食加工ゲーなので
工芸の分野は
コンセプトやメッセージから始まらずに木
4と素材そこを選んでスタートするからだ
と
技法と素材のこだわりを捨てない限り
君は本物にはなれないよとそう言われたん
です
どれだけ作品に工夫をしていても
どれだけメッセージを込めていても
染色の技法を使っちゃえば染色じゃんとは
口に当てて作品を見てないかなと
分野の枠組みが定められているような気が
して窮屈な思いをしていました
それからどこへ行ってもその扱いなさに
敏感になってしまいました言われた言葉が
呪えのよりのしかかって私から制作の楽し
さや発表の自身がどんどんなくなっていき
ました
次第にそういう暗黙のヒエラルキーがある
んだなと
これが普通で当たり前とそう考えを
落とし込むことにしました
でもそういうものなんだと納得すればする
ほど
私の中のマグマは消えませんでした
そこでバクに収めた評価ができなくなる
ような作品を作ってやろうと気合を
入れ直しました
言われてたその技法と素材それを使い
ながらも
両駅を超えるような展示を試みたんです
空間から平気面から徐々に空間や立体に
広がっていきもちろん技法素材と技法を
造形として極めつつその素材でしかでき
ないことを引き出して展開していきました
様々な試みの中でも
技法と素材このこだわりだけは絶対に譲れ
ませんでした
バカにされてた分野でもやっぱりそれは私
が愛した分野だったからです
私の歓声に応えてくれる
技法や素材があって製作するために私とし
て生まれてきて良かったと自分を肯定
できる時間だったからです
自分を生かしてくれて育ててくれて導いて
くれた分野に
性を背けることはできませんでした
だから既成概念を使いながらもそこから
発見を見いだし自由になる方法を探しまし
た
ではどのようにして探していったのか
大きな既成概念の枠を壊すために日常の
小さな既成概念に疑問を向けその発見を
作品に取り込むようにしたんです
これは空間に8個良いそうを浮かした作品
です
皆さんも図工の時間とか美術室で使った
ことあるんじゃないでしょうか懐かしい
ですか
晴れ結構しっかりできてってずっしり
重たいですよねもうお察しの通りでほっ
パンは重たいものは浮かばないという既成
概念からです
そこから絞りの頑丈さや
などの伸縮性を使って重たいものを固定
できるという発見に結びつけました
重たいものがバランスを取りながら宙を
舞っている
この緊張感を伝える空間作りを目指したん
ですがもちろんこれができるというデータ
や方法はコミュの中にはないので制作をし
ながら一から考え直しました
写真のようにヒモでこうダサいんですけど
ヒモでい走行一つずつ釣って絞りを絡めて
で最初の日も切ったらもう全部貨車閉じて
でまた次にコーヒも一から引っ張り直して
空間をつくってこここだわりたいってやっ
てたら国がが者と地点というのをだいたい
あと2回ぐらい繰り返してこの作品はでき
ています
別の作品も見てみましょう
皆さんカーテンしていても光が透けて
眩しいっていう時ありますよね
これはそういう布は光を通すという既成
概念から
光の透過で作品の印象を変えるという発見
に結びついたものです
光の助け方を効果的に伝えるために昼間の
自然光が外から入っている様子と中の中
からライトを当てている様子この2
パターンを展示することにしました
もちろんこれの絞り方や好き方のデータ
なんてこの世の中にないので一からスーツ
制作しながらその研究をするように制作
方法を考えました
もちろん搬入の時も微調整を繰り返し
ながら何度も透け感を確認して制作をして
いきます
さっき観ていただいたように昼間は渦の
このすぼまって行く先が暗くて見えないん
ですけど夜になるとショーウィンドウの中
からライトがついて暗かった打つの中心が
まるで発砲しているように明るく見えると
思います
一見すれば行く先は暗く見えないものに
なっているけど向かう先は軽く希望がある
というのがこの作品のメッセージです
一方で
絞るという政策の行為を生かしてこの
パフォーマンスを六本木の街中で行った
ことがあります
この芋虫は私です
布を折りたたんで絞るという既成概念から
布は圧縮されるという発見を得たことが
きっかけです
袋状になった布の中に私が入って外側江寧
ながら絞っていくんですけどそうすると
どんどん布が宿されて中がきつくなります
沢山の絞りに行こう作者が埋没される頃に
は袋の中から本当に出ることもできずに
そこで果てて終わりを迎えるという
こう
群衆が一人のポジんお前没していく様子を
ストレートに表現しました
今行っている取り組みを紹介させて
ください
皆さん今日着てきた服は柔らかいから切れ
ましたよね
これはそういう布は柔らかいという既成
概念から動かして作品の形を変えるという
発見に結びつけたものです
これは絞りと電動劇を使って作品を動かし
ています
今はこう
工芸と高額のパラボレーションというん
でしょうか
これにはまだ大きな壁があるんですが
様々な要素を取り入れて新しい表現を獲得
しようと日々模索をしています
今まで見ていたい観ていただいた作品も
それ以外も表現方法は一見バラバラです
でも技法と素材このこだわりを譲らなかっ
たことでそれが作品のマーク誰が見ても
松本の絞りの作品と分かるようになりまし
た
こだわりとは何をするかだけではなく何を
しないかにもパーソナリティーが出てき
ます
それは決してネガティブなことではあり
ません
自分の個性が何があるか分からないときは
自分は何をしないかで考えてみるのもひと
つの方法です
見えない制限が個性となって現れてきます
ここまでを通して皆さんにお伝えしたい
ことは
血の涙を流して既成概念を憎めということ
ではなく
既成概念の裏返しには発見があり制限を
課すことで個性が出るということです
私は分野の枠という既成概念にいながらも
それを壊すために発見を作品に取り入れて
制作をしました
そこでかけた制限が個性となって今の私の
活動を支えています
自分が当たり前と思っていた世界と
ひっくり返して向き合うには勇気と
やっぱりきっかけが入ります
これって何でこうなんだろうと疑問を抱い
たときだけではなく春丸なんてと言われて
悔しいときもきっかけです
言われた言葉が何度も頭の中でリフレイン
して本当に何もできないと呪いをかけられ
たようになるかもしれません
でもその時に隠された既成概念を見つけ
出すんです
その裏側にはあなたなりの発見があって
あなたなりの答えがあります
自分が押しつぶされないためにもどうか
呪いを発見に変えてください
正解のないものかもしれません方法も
データもこの世の中にはないかもしれませ
ん
でもそれにとらわれている時よりきっと
明るいところへあなたを導いてくれるはず
です
以上ですありがとうございました
[拍手]